>>> ONLY ON "CBS THIS MORNING,"
WE ARE CELEBRATING OUR NEW
NATIONAL TEACHER OF THE YEAR,
JULIANA URTUBEY, AS YOU JUST
SAW, ALONG WITH FIRST LADY DR.
JILL BIDEN.
BOTH ARE JOINING US WITH
PROPERLY SOCIAL DISTANCING FROM
INNOVATIVE ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IN
LAS VEGAS WHERE JULIANA
TEACHERS.
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU.
DR. JILL BIDEN, WELCOME, AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THIS WAS SO NICE OF YOU TO DO.
I KNOW THAT YOU AND YOUR TEAM
REARRANGED YOUR SCHEDULES SO
THAT YOU COULD BE IN NEVADA THIS
MORNING.
WE ARE SO GRATEFUL.
AND YOU CAME BRINGING FLOWERS,
DR. BIDEN.
THAT'S SO LOVELY!
WHY DID YOU WANT TO BE HERE
TODAY?
IT'S SO NICE.
>> OH, MY GOSH.
I'M SO EXCITED BECAUSE, YOU
KNOW, JULIANA IS OUR NATIONAL
TEACHER OF THE YEAR.
AND I'M SO PROUD TODAY TO BE AN
EDUCATOR.
BECAUSE LOOK AT JULIANA.
I MEAN, SHE IS JUST THE EPITOME
OF A GREAT TEACHER, A GREAT
EDUCATOR.
>> JULIANA, WHAT DID YOU THINK
WHEN THE FIRST LADY WALKED IN?
>> I WAS OBVIOUSLY ELATED.
I MEAN, IT'S SO AMAZING.
AND I'M SO GRATEFUL FOR A CHANGE
OF TONE OF POSITIVITY, OF
FOCUSING ON EDUCATION TO GET OUR
STUDENTS WHAT THEY NEED.
IT'S SO BEAUTIFUL.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT YOUR
STUDENTS NEED.
FORGIVE ME IF I'M PUFFY AS I
DELIVER THERE QUESTION, YOU GOT
ME FOR EMOTIONAL.
AS YOU WERE CRYING WATCHING YOUR
STUDENTS TALK ABOUT YOU, MY
MOM'S A TEACHER.
IT GETS ME EMOTIONAL.
I -- I THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR
WORK.
WHAT DO TEACHERS NEED?
YOU'RE NOW IN A POSITION WHERE
YOU CAN TALK ABOUT WHAT'S
REQUIRED.
SO WHAT'S AT THE TOP OF YOUR
LIST?
>> WELL, YOU NAMED IT.
YOU KNOW, TEACHING IS HEART TO
WORK, A WORK OF THE HEART.
IT'S ABOUT CONNECTING AND MAKING
RELATIONSHIPS.
I'M ADVOCATING FOR STUDENTS TO
HAVE A JOYOUS AND JUST
EDUCATION.
WHERE THEY EXPERIENCE JOY IN
EVERY PART OF THEIR SCHOOL.
>> I'M SORRY, I DIDN'T MEAN TO
INTERRUPT YOU.
DR. BIDEN, I WANT TO ECHO WHAT
JULIANA SAID AS THE HUSBAND OF A
TEACHER.
I SO APPRECIATE YOU -- YOU
SHOWING UP FOR THIS AND
HIGHLIGHTING TEACHERS AND THE
INCREDIBLE WORK JULIANA AND THE
OTHERS ARE DOING.
YOU YOURSELF HAVE CONTINUED
TEACHING.
WHY WAS IT IMPORTANT FOR YOU TO
DO THAT?
>> BECAUSE THAT'S MY PROFESSION.
I LOVE TEACHING.
AND -- AND PART OF MY PLATFORM
AS FIRST LADY IS TO LIFT UP
TEACHERS AND LIFT UP OUR
PROFESSION.
FOR SO LONG TEACHERS WERE
UNDERVALUED.
BUT NOW HOPEFULLY, YOU KNOW, ALL
OF AMERICA AFTER THIS PANDEMIC
HAS SEEN WHAT TEACHERS HAVE DONE
AND HOW THEY'VE JUST TAKEN CARE
OF OUR KIDS.
IT'S JUST BEEN SUCH A TOUGH
TIME.
AND TEACHERS HAVE RISEN TO THIS
MOMENT.
>> I HAVE TO SAY, DR. BIDEN,
WHEN YOU SAID YOU WERE HERE
BEFORE THE ELECTION, YOU SAID,
YOU KNOW, WHEN WE GET INTO THE
WHITE HOUSE, I WILL CONTINUE TO
TEACH.
AND I SAID, NO WAY IS SHE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT AS FIRST
LADY, BUT YOU HAVE CERTAINLY
DONE THAT.
SO BRAVO, BRAVO.
>> YES, I HAVE.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK SCHOOLS
NEED MOST?
IT'S BEEN A TOUGH YEAR FOR ALL
OF US AND CERTAINLY FOR THE
TEACHERS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK SCHOOLS NEED
MOST AS MANY PREPARE TO REOPEN?
WHAT'S ON YOUR WISH LIST?
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK SCHOOLS
NEED THE MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT
BOTH FOR THE STUDENTS AND THE
TEACHERS.
THIS HAS BEEN SUCH A TOUGH YEAR.
AND A LOT OF STUDENTS WHO HAVE
BEEN AT HOME HAVE, YOU KNOW,
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS ON THE
RISE, CHILD ABUSE IS ON THE
RISE, AND SO I THINK, YOU KNOW,
THE KIDS HAVE BEEN HURTING THIS
YEAR.
AND SO THEY'RE GOING TO NEED A
LOT OF SUPPORT.
AND THAT'S WHAT OUR
ADMINISTRATION, THAT'S WHAT JOE
HAS PROVIDED FOR.
>> JULIANA, YOU KNOW, WE'VE HAD
NATIONAL TEACHERS OF THE YEAR
FROM DIFFERENT FIELDS, SOME ARE
MUSIC TEACHERS, SOME ARE GYM
TEACHERS, ENGLISH TEACHERS.
YOU'RE AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
TEACHER, AND NOT ONLY AN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL TEACHER BUT IF
I SAW THE BIO CORRECTLY, YOU'RE
A SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHER IN
PARTICULAR.
WHAT CAN YOU SAY ABOUT THAT
SUBSPECIALTY WHICH IS SO
IMPORTANT TO SO MANY FAMILIES IN
THIS COUNTRY?
>> MY JOB IS TO MAKE SURE THAT I
HELP MY STUDENTS FIND THEIR
STRENGTHS.
KIDS WITH THINKING AND LEARNING
DIFFERENCES HAVE SO MANY
POSSIBILITIES, SO MUCH
POTENTIAL.
IT'S MY JOB TO FIND IT, MAKE
THEM BELIEVE IT, AND THEN HELP
THEM GROW.
>> AS THE NATIONAL TEACHER OF
THE YEAR, THAT IS NO SMALL
TITLE.
YOU'RE IN A POSITION NOW TO
ADVOCATE FOR EDUCATORS AND FOR
STUDENTS.
WHAT'S AT THE TOP OF THE LIST?
WHAT DO YOU THINK PEOPLE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND ABOUT WHAT WE NEED --
HOW WE NEED TO ADDRESS EDUCATION
IN THIS COUNTRY?
>> YOU KNOW, EACH SCHOOL IS
UNIQUE, AND THEY HAVE THEIR OWN
SPECIAL SET OF NEEDS.
SO THAT'S WHY I'M ADVOCATING FOR
A JOYOUS AND JUST EDUCATION.
JOY BECAUSE WE UNDERSTAND AND
UPLIFT EACH CHILD AND JUST
BECAUSE TEACHERS ARE WORKING
COLLECTIVELY TO BUILD LEARNING
SPACES WHERE ALL OF OUR STUDENTS
CAN THRIVE.
>> YOU KNOW, DR. BIDEN, WE HEARD
FROM JULIANA ABOUT WHY SHE LOVES
TEACHING SO MUCH.
YOU HAD A VERY FULL PLATE AS
FIRST LADY OF THE UNITED STATES.
WHY DO YOU STILL LOVE IT SO MUCH
AFTER ALL THIS TIME?
AND YOU CLEARLY DO.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I'M JUST LIKE
JULIANA.
IT'S THE STUDENTS.
THEY MAKE SUCH A DIFFERENCE.
AND I THINK, YOU KNOW, IT'S OUR
JOB TO GIVE THEM CONFIDENCE AND
GIVE THEM SKILLS.
AND LIKE JULIANA SAID, TO GIVE
THEM JOY AND SUPPORT IN THEIR
LIVES.
AND THAT'S OUR JOB.
AND THAT'S WHAT I LOVE ABOUT
TEACHING.
THAT I HOPE THAT I'M ABLE TO DO
THAT JUST LIKE JULIANA HAS DONE
IN HER CLASSROOM.
>> YOU KNOW, GUYS, I DO WANT TO
ASK ONE QUESTION THAT IS A BIT
POLICY RELATED.
I DID A LONG STORY ABOUT A YEAR
AGO ABOUT TEACHER PAY.
AND I MET TEACHERS WHO WERE
WORKING SECOND JOBS JUST SO THEY
CAN MAINTAIN THE JOB THAT THEY
REALLY WANT TO DO WHICH IS
EDUCATING THE NEXT GENERATION.
IT'S A BIG ISSUE.
EVERYBODY GETS EMOTIONAL ABOUT
TEACHERS.
EVERYONE LOVES TO SEE A DAY LIKE
THIS.
WE ALL SHED TEARS AT HOME.
BUT THEN WHEN IT COMES TO VOTING
TO INCREASE TEACHER PAY, PEOPLE
GET A LITTLE SHY.
WHAT'S YOUR MESSAGE TO THOSE
PEOPLE?
>> TEACHERS ARE PROFESSIONALS.
THEY'RE OUTSTANDING, THEY GROW
THEIR CRAFT, AND I THINK TEACHER
PAY IS SOMETHING THAT IS GOING
TO BE SO IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY AS
WE TRY TO GROW AND RETAIN AND
RECRUIT TEACHERS.
WE NEED TO TREAT TEACHERS LIKE
PROFESSIONALS AND OUTSTANDING
PROFESSIONALS THAT THEY ARE.
>> YEAH.
>> DR. BIDEN, LISTEN, WHEN YOU
SEE THE PRESIDENT LATER TODAY,
MAKE SURE YOU TOLD HIM YOU
STARTED YOUR DAY WITH US.
WHAT MESSAGE WILL YOU BRING TO
HIM ABOUT JULIANA AND HER
NATIONAL TEACHER OF THE YEAR
AWARD?
IN LESS THAN 30 SECONDS, YES.
>> I WILL TELL HIM HOW WONDERFUL
SHE IS, HOW SHE LIFTS UP HER
STUDENTS, HOW SHE GIVES THEM JOY
BECAUSE THAT'S HER MESSAGE.
THAT'S WHO OUR TEACHERS ARE.
>> NICELY DONE.
BRAVO.
> CONGRATULATIONS, JULIANA.
THANK YOU, DR. BIDEN.
>> FLOWERS AND EVERYTHING.
I LOVED IT.
GOOD TO SEE YOU BOTH.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BAC